Робочі будні Людмили Ступіної.
Ось уже два роки вона працює таксисткою в Тамані.
Проживають у місті близько десяти тисяч людей.
Доволі багато місцевих знають Людмилу.
У Тамань вона переїхала з Уралу.
Людмила розповідає, що в багатьох, хто тут живе,
є родичі в Україні.
Зазвичай люди, коли сідають у її таксі, не хочуть
говорити про політику. Навіть попри події,
що відбуваються буквально за рогом.
- Люди намагаються про це не говорити.
Немає, як ви самі бачили, жодної паніки.
Єдине, що це близько, але я, наприклад, упевнена, що нічого не буде.
На місцевому ринку люди зізнаються: нещодавні події в Керченській протоці занепокоїли їх.
- Ми тут, Тамань перша, тут біля нас це все. Теж страшно.
- Та ні, не страшно. Та мені здається, нічого не буде.
- Такі браття були, ми ж постійно добре жили,
туди їздили, в Україну, в Києві були, всюди… як рідні були.
- Та ж політики більш серйозні, що ж ми, люди рядові...
Але неприємно, не хочеться такого. Миру хочеться, тож це нас зовсім не влаштовує.
Тамань - найближчий населений пункт у Росії
до Керченського мосту.
Напруга в Азовському морі зросла в останні місяці,
особливо з моменту відкриття мосту в травні.
Людмила переїхала в Тамань, щоб бути ближче до моря.
Іноді вона приходить сюди, щоб відпочити від роботи,
навіть узимку. Людмила розповідає, що її родичі, які
лишилися в Єкатеринбурзі, хвилюються за неї.
Утім, сама жінка налаштована оптимістично.
- Море мене заспокоює. Іноді навіть
на якесь запитання хочу почути відповідь.
І я кажу собі: от якщо щось вийде, наступна хвиля буде велика.
- Є надія, що наш уряд все врегулює, що все буде нормально, і ми усі будемо жити в мирі.
Сьогодні на морі шторм.
А мешканців Тамані не полишає запитання:
коли вже припиниться шторм у великій політиці?